dimanche secours la dernière étape
comment voyez vous cette étape compte
tenu du musical de invensys que possède
salinas sur violence il reste
heureusement qu il savait au moins de
trois ans que c'était cette étape là
elle est en la jouant on l'a fait parce
que avant enfin de la hollande
on a tranquillement sur la matière mais
ça fait deux trois ans maintenant dès le
départ donné à rivière-pilote et à des
baroudeurs qui met en route à la course
elle a très vite on a constaté que
depuis le début du tout on a toujours
des moyens de 40
donc demain il ya trois ans je pense que
les 3 4 points et les 3 4 premiers sont
dans des mouchoirs de poche donc ce qui
veut dire qu'il y aura une grosse
bagarre demain la moyenne générale est
de quand le métro pour l'instant un tout
très rapide mettrait beaucoup de dégâts
à peine 76 coups en compétition oui
c'est sûr en plus ce matin nous avons
pas eu de cours ce qui veut dire que
demain nous allons repartir avec au
moins trois quatre coureurs de moins et
il y avait beaucoup de déchet parce que
beaucoup de coups on n'a pas compris
qu'il faut préparer à tout prix presque
tous ont pris part ils veulent venir sur
le tour mais sa préparation à notre
vidéo que des délais troy merritt a
pignon sur rue dans la course quoi si on
pose la question qui remporte le tour
que répondez vous à moi je dis toujours
quand on affiche fille franchi la ligne
dimanche on peut dire celui qui a gagné
le tour mais pour l'instant il ya
salinas qui a quand même une belle
avance et puis bon ben il est bien il
est costaud il a une bonne équipe donc
ce sera un peu difficile à amortir ce
maillot sur lui